there's a debate today unfortunately i
can't be there because i'm i have a
long-standing engagement up here uh but
i never want to focus the opposition
obviously want to focus on a particular
case a particular mp who uh suffered a
serious personal tragedy and who's now
resigned can i just finish off
and what what we want to do and i and i
frankly you know i don't think there's
much more to be said
about that particular case i really
don't but what we do need to do
is look also at
the process and
that is what we were trying to do last
week and what i hope is that there will
be
through the good offices of the speaker
and i'm if i what i read and i hear uh
that hope may be well founded there will
be cross-party agreement on a way
forward uh including an appeals process
for very difficult
and very sad cases such as the one we've
seen
there's been long-standing
uh
concerns amongst uh mps across the the
house of commons about the about the
process what we're seeing now is what we
see what we're seeing now is
a i think if i understand things
correctly the speaker is saying he wants
to have a
a cross-party approach to look at the
issue of appeals in particularly
difficult cases i totally support that